ab jetzt ist alles möglich so jetzt
haben wir langsam Bahn Chaos hier
wenn ich den verpasse dann war es das
ganz bitter das ist so chaotisch würde
hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gedacht
vollkommen ist Chaos auch mittlerweile
gar nichts mehr zu Essen eigentlich auch
gerade gar nicht mehr aussprechen
hi ich bin Julian und ich bin Reporter
bei Bild und ich wage etwas was ich
glaube ich in diesem Land noch keiner
zugetraut hat ich will Deutschlands
längste Bahnstrecke fahren von ganzem
Norden bis ganz im Süden und zwar mit
diesem Ding hier das ist mein
deutschland-ticket das bedeutet nicht
schön komfortabel irgendwie mit dem ICE
sondern mit dem langsamsten das heißt er
eh es war Himmel Zug die Bahn sagt das
dauert 17 Stunden 20 und in denen wir es
auch schaffen ich würde innerhalb eines
Tages von Westerland auf Sylt ist eine
Bahnhof ganz unten in den Süden fahren
nach Oberstdorf das ist fast schon eine
österreichischen Grenze wie gesagt 17
Stunden 20 innerhalb eines Tages das ist
die Herausforderung das ist eine Strecke
die kein Mensch freiwillig fahren würde
und warum mache ich es weil ich dieses
deutschland-ticket einfach mal bewusst
beim Namen nehmen ich will das ganze
Land mit diesem Ticket sehen und
deswegen heißt es das Handy das Ticket
und ich im Kampf gegen die Zeit ob es
wirklich klappt nein nein nein nein
ja überragend also bei dieser Motivation
kann ich nur noch sagen los geht's
[Musik]
kleinere Problem würde ich sagen hatte
ich irgendwie nicht ganz am Schirm das
ist so früh noch kein Frühstück gibt na
ja mal gucken ja ich fahre jetzt erstmal
gleich ein Stück und schnell irgendwo
was essen finde da ist der Zug
keine Leute da
von gestern
die ersten zwei Minuten lang fahren wir
sind tatsächlich pünktlich losgefahren
und es geht jetzt erstmal bis nach
Elmshorn das sind so da steht hier
knapp
[Musik]
also wir sind immer drei Tage da da
hier ich dachte sie müssten täglich
seit 17 Jahren Penne der von Liebe nach
Sylt und arbeitet auch seit 17 Jahren im
Nachtdienst da bei dem Hotel und werden
meinte
es muss wohl schlimm sein vom Festland
nach Sylt zu pennen
[Musik]
ich habe es tatsächlich schon geschafft
bis Hamburg ist auch noch alles im
Zeitplan bin jetzt etwas über drei
Stunden unterwegs seit 5 Uhr heute
Morgen wach
[Musik]
ja
Süd bis nach Oberstdorf
ja in 17 Stunden 40 gefahren
hier und da natürlich kneifen aber ich
denke einmal durchs ganze Stunde
Herausforderung aber du bist zu strecken
funktioniert gut es gibt Leute die
optimistisch sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen im wunderbaren Öl zurück
tatsächlich seit 2001 100 Wasserbahnhof
12:23 Uhr wir stecken in Hannover fest
aber das tolle ist hier in den Zügen
Steckdosen ja
ckdose
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt tatsächlich in Göttingen
so jetzt ist das Problem
neubieten sollte eigentlich genau jetzt
fahren
[Musik]
ich habe es geschafft ich bin auf
bayrischem Boden Würzburg jetzt erstmal
alles was jetzt nach wird wo kommt wird
extrem stressig weil die Umsteigezeiten
einfach so klasse sind
[Musik]
raus
so jetzt haben wir langsam fahren
eigentlich essen wir vor
knapp 9 Minuten losfahren müssen ich
stehe immer noch Würzburg eine halbe
Stunde bist durchlegen aber es sieht so
aus als hätte immer noch Verspätung das
heißt ich werde leider dann den
Anschlusszug nach Augsburg verpassen
keine Ahnung weiter geht aber ich habe
das große Glück hier im Zug äh gut
Unterhaltung gefunden
[Musik]
ja ich habe tatsächlich nach
Treuchtlingen geschafft es ist furchtbar
ich weiß jetzt gerade auch gar nicht wo
ich hingehe ich sitze tatsächlich mit
dem Zug war noch komplettes Chaos weil
der Zug von Treuchtlingen hatte
Verspätung und eigentlich hätte ich
jetzt mein Anschluss zu verpasst dann
dieses plötzlich aber die alle
anstoßzüge warten und dann kam aber das
mein Anschluss Zug den ich eigentlich
nehmen wollte
dass der so viel Verspätung hat deswegen
habe ich gedacht ich hätte Zeit und
plötzlich ist es aber doch und dann muss
ich Rennen jetzt sitze ich hier in dem
Zug der war auch schon wieder 10 Minuten
Verspätung hat ich habe jetzt auch
mittlerweile gar nichts mehr zu essen
also das ist so chaotisch würde hätte
ich jetzt auch nicht gehört ihr merkt
die Stimmung ist eigentlich noch ganz
gut
in Augsburg habe ich fünf Minuten Zeit
und beim nächsten danach das ist dann in
Buchloe oder Buchloe auch noch nie
gehört 3 Minuten
[Musik]
dann ist vorbei ich muss irgendwie vier
fünf Stunden irgendwo in der
bayerischen Provinz
[Musik]
die gekoppelt werden
sind nie ein Zeichen von Pünktlichkeit
glaube ich
das war jetzt eine
zugüberholung wird immer wieder die war
auch nicht vorgesehen
wahrscheinlich genau in diesem
Augenblick verlässt du übrigens mein
Nachfolge zu den Hauptbahnhof Augsburg
immer dunkler dunkler und dunkler
nur eine Viertelstunde Zeit wir werden
immer die drei nächsten Wand Ausdruck
ist noch nicht drauf
und Zug Überholung leider 10 Minuten zu
spät Scheiße
die Deutsche Bahn hat es nicht geschafft
zu halten
weil dann habe ich gleich 9 Minuten
umsteigen wenn ich dann hoffentlich den
letzten Zug des Tages
aber wenn ich den verpasse
dann dann war es das ist tatsächlich
geschafft fast hier steht der Zug nach
Oberstdorf da es scheint als für Dich
heute noch wirklich an antik kommt krass
und so viel zu eins nicht mehr mit
gerechnet ich würde sagen
einsteigen und und
das spektakulär
aber
da hinten geht es nicht mehr weiter ich
habe es geschafft ich bin am südlichsten
Bahnhof Deutschlands
unter den Oberstdorf gelandet
längste Bahnstrecke Deutschlands
Gefahren von von Sylt bis nach
Oberstdorf innerhalb eines Tages es ist
jetzt 0:40 Uhr
dann habe ich glaube ich 18 Stunden und
20 Minuten gebraucht
200 Tortur ich halt so viel Spaß gemacht
wie erwartet
ich habe viel von diesem Land gesehen
viele Leute getroffen ja ich bin einfach
froh oh das jetzt geschafft haben das
ist geschafft ist
und jetzt gucke ich nur noch dass ich
irgendwie im Bett finde
und schlafen kann
hier ist jetzt noch mein kleines Fazit
ich muss sagen ich war wirklich
überrascht dass es am Ende nur eine
Stunde Verspätung war wenn der Vater
habe ich paar mal gedacht ich komme
überhaupt nicht mehr lebend in
Oberstdorf an mein Rad an euch ist noch
wenn euch eure Lebenszeit irgendwie
irgendwas wert ist dann macht das auf
gar keinen Fall nach wenn durch
Deutschland dann einfach den ICE nehmen